Justice Department Inspector General
Michael Horowitz testified before the
Senate yesterday on his report and it
turns out you're gonna be shocked to
hear this that the mainstream media have
been lying to us about everything on the
same day the New York Times reported
that President Trump was redefining
Judaism as a nationality sparking
widespread hysteria comparisons to the
Nazis before it turned out that their
report was completely false then as the
cherry on top of the fake news Sunday
CNN's Don Lemon had a meltdown on air
over a meme over nothing we will examine
why and how the fake news lie so well
then a new study shows the loneliness
epidemic is affecting the young more
than the old that's not good news
finally the mail bag all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the media have been lying to us about
everything now I know that's not exactly
a Man Bites Dog story we've known that
generally for a long time but so many
fake stories so many important fake
stories collapse its collapsed yesterday
all at once and we got to watch it in
real time I want to begin before we get
to the actual meat of these lies the
actual meat of this hysteria and
nonsense
I want to start this delicious meal of
fake news with the dessert first I want
to start it with that little cherry on
top of the chocolate sundae I want to
start it with CNN where CNN's Don Lemon
decided to skip over all of the actual
news and having a breakdown in on-air
hysterical breakdown because President
Trump's campaign team tweeted out a meme
in addition to all the lies and all the
blustering at tonight's rally Trump's
war ruin posted a meme on Twitter today
showing Trump as a super villain Thanos
from the Marvel Avengers movies
dispatching his Democratic in enemies
take a look at this
in any on the solemn day and I recoils
at the first forward business from
members of
what are we in junior high school like
what the hell what is this like what
what I cannot believe it I'm even having
to report this on the news this is core
this is crazy this is literally crazy
are you people insane it goes on it in
some ways it even gets better
the key takeaway though here for me is
that Don Lemon and CNN and the
mainstream media overall are always
projecting they call Trump a liar they
lie more than Trump they say that Trump
is behaving in an immature manner they
behave in a much more immature manner
they say Trump is vulgar they're more
vulgar I mean he says what what are we
what are we in in middle school with the
hell what is this crap he says crap
later on in the what what is he stumbles
this silent he's befuddled he says like
what is this like like what is yeah you
are behaving like you're in junior high
school Don Lemon he says in there he
says I can't believe I actually have to
cover this you don't have to cover it
this is not news this is a Twitter
account run by one of the Trump campaign
officials tweeting out a funny meme on
the internet which is made for memes you
that's not news you don't have to cover
that at all you're choosing to cover
that because you're a fake news
organization so you don't want to cover
the good jobs numbers you don't want to
cover the devastating Horowitz testimony
then the Nets didn't even cover the
Horowitz testimony they've been
streaming the ridiculous impeachment
testimony back-to-back wall-to-wall
coverage for weeks now and then the
devastating Horowitz testimony on the
abuses in the FBI in the DOJ well that
one they can't cover they don't have
time they've got to cover memes on
Twitter instead and it gets worse than
that the news stories get even worse
than that we'll start with the Horowitz
desdemonia but then we'll go through a
whole confection of lies before we do
that though I have got to thank our
friends over at expressvpn you know
we've been having a debate all week long
among conservatives especially about
what kind of stuff you should be able to
look at on the internet if you should be
able to look at some of that
scintillating titillating not-so-great
kind of stuff on the Internet and then
some people are saying you shouldn't and
some people are saying you should but
you can skip the whole debate when you
just encrypt your data with vpm and you
don't need to worry about it at the
Daily wire we invest thousands of
dollars in cybersecurity because we are
regularly the target of attacks now as
an individual Internet user you don't
need to have a whole IT department to
protect you from online threats what you
do need is expressvpn you know how much
I love expressvpn I've been talking
about it on my show for so long that you
understand why encrypting your data is
so important some of you still haven't
acted why is that I don't think it's
cheapness because it's so cheap to use
Express VPN it's so inexpensive I think
it's like laziness and this feeling that
nobody wants your data right your data
that's totally fine they just want
everybody else's wrong buddy not using
Express VPN is like leaving your front
door unlocked every time you go out and
if you listen to this show you probably
look at some pretty weird stuff online
in that old incognito window so one of
the easiest ways to secure your data is
with expressvpn why haven't you gotten
Express VPN yet right now visit my
special link Express VPN dot-com /
michael mi CH AE l get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free that is my
Christmas gift to you protect your
Internet today do it seriously he will
regret it if you don't use the VPN that
I trust to keep my data safe go to
Express VPN dot-com / Michael mi CH AE L
to get started so beyond Don lemons
meltdown on CNN you saw when you when
you look really closely into the media
which we're basically blocking at the
Horowitz testimony when you were
streaming it from c-span and getting it
on the Internet
you could see that the media story on
this whole three-year we
I'll use Trump's term whose Trump's term
is right this whole three-year witch
hunt the media's story collapsed and it
collapsed in particular with the
testimony of the Justice Department
Inspector General Michael Horowitz so
the mainstream media have been telling
us for months now
that there was no problem with the
Russia investigation there was no no
spying on the Trump campaign and even if
they did spy it's not a big deal they've
now told us since the IG released his
report over just the past few days that
the IG report vindicated James Comey
vindicated the FBI officials vindicated
all the people who were spying on the
Trump campaign so Michael Horowitz let's
get it in your own words the words of
the inspector general did the Obama
administration illegally spy on the
Trump campaign so let's play this out
they never told Trump about the concerns
is it fair to say they came a point to
where surveilling Carter page became
unlawful I will let the Court decide
that the court has this report and will
make that decision let's put it this way
if you don't have a legal foundation to
surveil somebody and you keep doing it
is that bad absolutely is that spine
it's it's not it's illegal surveillance
it's not court authorized a lence means
they did it I love this answer because
Michael Horowitz wants to be measured he
doesn't want to be partisan he's the
Inspector General for goodness sake
the media have just been talking about
what a great guy he is because his
report that nobody has read is 400 page
report that not a soul has actually read
is is said to have vindicated James
Comey in the FBI right he says was it
bad that's what Lindsey Graham asks
Horowitz was what the FBI did with
regard to FISA abuse was it bad Horowitz
says yes and he says was it illegal yes
was it
spying well it was illegal surveillance
okay fine you want to sound more mesh
apparently spying is a bad word now
William bar the Attorney General made a
joke about that
he said spying is not intrinsically a
bad thing it depends on whether the
spying was legitimately predicated it
depends on whether the spying was legal
or illegal so he says it's bad it's
illegal and it was illegal surveillance
which is to say illegal spying oK we've
established that then Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham Beau asks Horowitz the
media has been reporting that your
report exonerates the FBI and all those
senior officials does it is the FBI
exonerated do they look good after this
report or do they look really really bad
I sinner tell us very quickly I think
and blues all makes good point how would
you describe the behavior here and
knowing that the sub source disavows the
dossier that was the primary reason we
got a warrant finding it a lawyer doctor
than email to keep the investigation
going in a way unfair to mr. Page this
is not routine do you agree with that it
is definitely not it is it certainly
better not be routine and I don't know
any reason to think it is routine is it
kind of off the charts bad it's pretty
bad
thank you it is it's pretty bad it's
kind of off the charts bad I by the way
I should just mention I love the Senate
Judiciary Committee because you get
Lindsey Graham Bo you get Lindsey Graham
2.0 and you also get Ted Cruz you get
mr. Zodiac himself who runs roughshod
for the leftist KC R on the IG report I
mean he Cruz is so good he is so in his
element when he's in these Senate
hearings and he goes even further than
Lindsey Graham he asks Horowitz let's
say that it wasn't protected people
let's say wasn't James Comey and very
protected people and the FBI and the DOJ
who were illegally spying on the Trump
campaign if it were just an ordinary
person Joe Blow off the street who
falsified these court documents would
that person be prosecuted horowitz's
answer is two
we will get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at Daniels
NYC I love this company Daniels NYC what
do they make they make excellent
briefcases now they also make belts I
love my Daniels belt that's now my
number one black belt but they primarily
make briefcases I've owned a lot of
briefcases I've owned very nice
briefcases Daniel's is my favorite
briefcase I've ever owned these guys
just get it and they make high-quality
excellent quality briefcases at a price
that you can afford that's accessible so
if you want to get a really nice
high-quality briefcase often it's $800
$1,000 more than that sometimes Daniels
brings that price way down and they
maintain the exact same high level
quality and frankly I think their
designs are better than most of the you
know name brands that you've all heard
of for 30 years Daniel's is designed in
New York City with working professionals
in mind it's a bag built for real life
that means high-quality durable Italian
leather daniel says even even I didn't
think it was possible but they've
actually up to their game even more
recently they have some of the finest
quality leather in the world simplicity
and design no flashy logos you're not
gonna look like you're some you know
rapper or something with all these big
gaudy logos and stuff it's just timeless
style that works no matter where you are
in your career it's just that classic
New York beautiful style they have a
really great subtle liners on the inside
so the designs are really nice it's
clean its sleek I can't speak highly
enough about this great Christmas
present if you're gonna give it to
somebody else and if you want to treat
yourself it's a good Christmas present
for you this week my listeners can get
$50 off their Daniels briefcase at
Daniel's NYC comm by using the promo
code Michael mi CH AE L at checkout
that's 50 bucks off one of their leather
briefcases plus they offer free shipping
free returns and free exchanges there's
no reason not to try it treat yourself
or a friend or a loved one this holiday
season with this one-of-a-kind gift if
it's just tremendous you will impress
everybody and functionally it's so great
a daniels NYC comm from encode michael
mi CH AE l for $50 off a handcrafted
high-quality leather briefcase with free
shipping
crews then goes further than Lindsey
Graham he says would an ordinary person
who acted in the way that these FBI
officials acted would they be prosecuted
in any ordinary circumstance if a
private citizen did this fabricated
evidence I would he inserted was not
just slightly wrong it was a hundred and
eighty degrees opposite what the
evidence said so the Intelligence Agency
said this guy is a source and he
inserted this guy is not a source if a
private citizen did that in any law
enforcement investigation if they
fabricated evidence and reversed what it
said in your experience with that
private citizen be prosecuted for
fabricating evidence be prosecuted for
obstruction of justice be prosecuted for
perjury they certainly would be
considered for that if there was an
intentional effort to deceive the court
on this one I'm going to defer because
as we noted here in in the sentence you
indicated we referred that over to the
Attorney General in the FBI director
friendly now this is an important answer
here because Horowitz look he's not he
doesn't want to come off as a partisan
so he answers right away would would an
ordinary citizen
be prosecuted for this well you know we
would certainly look into it we would
have to check it out but I don't want to
make that final judgment because I'm the
inspector general that's not my job
that's the job of the Justice Department
and the Attorney General and by the way
we've turned this matter over to the DOJ
and the Attorney General now you see the
key here what the media have wanted you
to believe since the IG report came out
is okay they're not going after anybody
they didn't find evidence of this awful
partisanship so never mind nothing to
see here moving along and what Bill Barr
and the prosecutor John Durham and
conservatives have been saying is the IG
is not tasked with going over and
pursuing criminal investigations that's
what we have this separate criminal
investigation for and what the left has
been saying is oh you're just trying to
spin it you're just trying to save face
after this IG report doesn't doesn't
implicate our guys doesn't incriminate
our guys and now you have the IG himself
saying it's not my job to pursue
criminal investigations that's the job
of the Attorney General and I have
referred this matter to him it means
there's some bad news coming for the
people who tried to overthrow the
president and overturn a presidential
election so what happens now Horowitz of
his own accord not even in the
questioning but in his own statement
admitted a bombshell yesterday he
admitted that the warrant to spy on the
Trump campaign came entirely from the
Democrat DNC Hillary Clinton funded
steel dossier 100% for example the
crossfire hurricane team obtained
information from Steele's primary sub
source in January 2017 that raised
significant questions about the
reliability of the steel reporting this
was particularly noteworthy
because the FISA applications relied
entirely on information from the from
the steel from the primary sub sources
reporting to support the allegation that
age was coordinating with the Russian
government on 2016 US presidential
election activities however that FBI did
not share this information with
department lawyers and it was therefore
omitted from the last two renewal
applications Wow
what that means is you had the steel
dossier this was contracted through
fusion gps by the Hillary Clinton
campaign and the DNC they engaged with a
foreign a former foreign intelligence
analyst who himself was dealing with for
even other foreign intelligence sources
namely in Russia and they compiled this
hit hit piece this Oppo uncorroborated
document on president Trump these
crooked officials at the FBI then used
the Democrat funded Oppo research as the
entire basis to spy on the Trump
campaign and then when it became clear
that so much of this was bunk that it
was
warranted that this the spying on
quarter-page
generally speaking was unwarranted they
omitted all of that information
including their source including the
funding for their source from the FISA
application that's a few too many errors
to chalk it up to accidents that's a
little too specific in those errors to
chalk it up to accidents this stinks to
high heaven which is why I strongly
suspect Michael Horowitz included that
in his statement and why he mentioned
that this has been referred for criminal
investigation at the level of the
Attorney General and that is what we're
going to see coming up on top of all of
this as the whole Russia hoax formally
collapses the whole predicate the whole
basis for spying on the Trump campaign
collapses there is a report out of the
Office of Management and Budget the
Office of Management and Budget out of
the White House releases a legal memo on
the Ukraine issue so not Russia not the
three years ago attempt to overthrow
Trump but they have three weeks ago
attempt to overthrow Trump the current
attempt they released a legal memo
indicating that the delay in US aid to
Ukraine which ostensibly was the source
of this whole nonsense was completely
routine completely routine here is what
the OMB released for decades OMB has
routinely used its apportionment
authority to prevent funds from being
used often in managing appropriations
OMB must briefly pause an agency's legal
ability to spend those funds for a
number of reasons including to ensure
that the funds are being spent
efficiently that they are being spent in
accordance with statutory directives or
to assess how or whether funds should be
used for a particular activity routine
normal happens all the time now we
should have already known this because
the Democrats actually are not pursuing
the Ukraine issue as the basis for
impeachment they could have they could
have charged Trump with bribery that
could have charged Trump with extortion
in regard to his phone call with Ukraine
they didn't do it because they don't
have any evidence for that so instead
they're charging with
two articles of impeachment abusive
power over our know whatever shrug I
mean it's as vague of charge as you can
get and obstruction of Congress because
only some people testified before the
impeachment inquiry by the way those
people all of whom either hadn't talked
to Trump about Ukraine or said
explicitly that there was no quid pro
quo from Trump's mouth but because of
that because only some people testified
that's obstruction of Congress which by
the way is the president's job is to
obstruct Congress so we already should
have known this Ukraine thing is bunk
but we get this memo out of the OMB and
guess what the news reports absolutely
nothing mean the media won't report on
this story gets even worse though
because yesterday the New York Times ran
a piece that was designed in many ways
and it was received in many ways to make
Trump look like Adolf Hitler and the
story was completely false we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at movement movement is
making the perfect gift is you know
movement movement now makes like
everything makes watches sunglasses blue
like glasses bracelets movement watches
are designed in house they're super
sleek they have these beautifully
curated gift boxes his and her as gift
guides free and quick shipping to your
door just in time for the holidays I
have gotten so many compliments on my
movement watches I'm partial to the
revolver collection I think that's the
coolest collection it's sleek it's a
retro in a certain way but it's not just
a repeat of some old watch it's also got
this kind of modern minimalism to it
last year I gave my father a movement
watch for Christmas he loved it he wears
it all the time it was probably the most
popular gift I've given and in recent
memory I mean since I was a kid movement
watches are starting at just $95 if you
were to go into a department store try
to buy a watch of this quality it would
be three four times that clean design
minimal a minimal design and really
really high-quality movement has sold
almost two million watches in over 160
countries be the big winner this holiday
season with a gift from movement get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Knowles canna WL
that is MVM t-dot-com / Knowles kena
wles
and join the movement a major fake news
story coming out of the New York Times
yesterday this was the tweet that that
The Times sent out President Trump will
sign an executive order defining Judaism
as a nationality not just a religion
bolstering the Education Department's
efforts to stamp out boycott Israel
movements on college campuses now in The
New York Times this defense I can't
believe I'm uh during that statement
they do frame the second half of this
story as a help from the White House for
the Jewish people for Jewish Americans
that's the second half of the story the
first half of the story
includes what should be just the facts
president Trump will sign an executive
order defining Judaism as a nationality
not just a religion this caused a lot of
concern a lot of hysteria on the left
because it evoked images of Nazi Germany
other ring Jews and making them seem not
American not part of this country this
is just another step in that those
brownshirt Trump supporters campaign of
anti-semitism and Nazism right a Mali
Jong fast who is a left-wing writer she
tweeted out quote my nationality is
American and this feels like it's
ultimately gonna be bad for Jews a lot
of other people were we're tweeting out
all sorts of things this is how it
begins this is how it began in Germany
is there gonna be other ditz in Germany
you had to have Jewish on your passport
and that that's what what America's
coming to and then it turned out this
story's completely false if you read the
executive order Trump did not define
Judaism as a nationality if you read the
executive order all he said was that
under title 6 where you can't
discriminate against people on the basis
of race or nationality it doesn't say
that you can't discriminate people
against people on the basis of religion
Trump said that his administration will
treat Jews for the
purposes of these civil rights
protections as though they had the same
protections as people on the basis of
race or nationality a wonderful thing
very nice thing to do for the Jewish
people obviously there were a lot of
Jewish activists who were in the White
House when President Trump was signing
this it was it was the left and the
times kind of started it but it was the
left more more broadly they were
actually even more guilty of this than
the New York Times they took a story
that was about Trump helping Jews and
they managed to turn it not just a
little bit but 180 degrees in the
opposite direction and turn it into a
story about how Trump is a Nazi that is
what we're up against that is what the
media do they have no credibility on
this stuff whatsoever what does this
mean for you and me what this means is
we have to not be taken in by the fancy
people who wear the ties and the jackets
who look like Don Lemon Don Lemon looks
so great doesn't he he looks like such a
serious guy he's a handsome guy he's got
that very serious face he's got his
jacket on and his tie so he would never
lie to you he would never behave like a
child on television he would never just
be a hack partisan who's attacking the
president for partisan reasons except
that's what they all do that's what the
whole mainstream media does and time
after time I think even many
conservatives want to give deference or
subconsciously or just brought in to
give deference to what you read in the
paper what you read online what you hear
from the TV news there's no reason to do
that at this point the partisan
political operatives and politicians in
the Trump administration have much much
more credibility than the New York Times
and CNN and the Washington Post and all
the others president Trump's Twitter
account I'm not saying Trump never
exaggerated so I'm not saying that
President Trump never stretches the
truth president Trump's Twitter account
has a greater record of honesty and
journalistic credibility then these
partisan
in the mainstream media that's what they
are and yet they won't admit it so what
we need to do is tune out of that stuff
all right it's I think it's perfectly
great to read honestly left-wing news
sources and opinion sources and I think
you should read honestly right-wing news
sources and commentary but for the
people who are pretending to report the
news they have no credibility they have
hollowed out these institutions from
within
they are just zombie New York Times and
zombie Washington Post who are not who
they used to be we will get to the
loneliness epidemic because it actually
the loneliness epidemic does tie back
into all the kind of political questions
and and political philosophical debates
we've been having all week on everything
from the role of government to internet
porn we'll get to that in a second we'll
get to the mailbag but first let me tell
you about the Daily wire store on Amazon
it's the perfect place to get your
holiday shopping needs from our classic
facts don't care about your feelings
shirts which is 15% off to our very
popular zero bark 30 shirt this is one
of my favorites we've ever done and I'm
wearing it right now even including all
the Christmas sweaters that we've got
even including our brand new Santha
Trump's hoax hoax hoax Merry Christmas
everybody you will find plenty of
goodies to make this the best
gift-giving season ever and if you buy
this week your orders will arrive just
in time for Christmas so head over to
the daily wire come and check out our
amazon store and let the shopping begin
that's over at daily wire.com and
actually in addition while you're there
you can save time and money this holiday
season by giving your loved ones a daily
wire gift membership which from now
until January 1st all insider plus gift
memberships will be 25% off so that's a
major major savings means that your
loved one will get this fantastic perk
all these great gifts the left is tears
tumblr and you will get the savings go
to daily wire.com slash gift get your
25% off daily wire.com slash gift 25%
off all insider plus gift memberships
this Christmas season give them the gift
they'll thank you for all year long
daily wire calm we'll be right back with
a lot more
before we go to the mailbag I have to
mention this this survey because it
tells us a lot about our culture and it
actually tells us about some of the
political debates we've been having a
study out of George Mason University of
1,200 people it's 1,200 Americans found
that one in three young people below the
age of 25 feel lonely whereas only 11%
of adults older than 65 feel the same
then this is on top of a survey out of
the United Kingdom which found that 40%
4-0 of young people 16 to 24 feel lonely
often or very often that's compared to
27% of adults over 75 this is a very
strange this is the opposite of what we
should expect historically speaking
older people people of a certain age you
know beginning 65 plus certainly by 75
certainly into your 80s feel lonely they
begin to feel lonely because they're
kind of set in their ways there it's
harder to make friends as you get older
perhaps they've had loved ones or
friends or spouses died and so just
naturally you feel lonelier at that
point very odd for young people in their
20s in their teens to feel lonelier than
senior citizens why is that happening
why is it I mean the researchers
conclude our research shows that
loneliness is a subjective mental state
rather than an age-related symptom why
is it why is this happening on top of
this we find antidepressant use up 65
percent in 15 years the highest rises
among young Americans teen suicide up 70
percent 0 7 0 % over just the past few
years marriage rates declining birth
rates declining we are very lonely we're
very very lonely you can look at the
technological aspects that isolate us
you can look at some of the social
aspects that isolate us I think there's
an ideological aspect to it gets to what
we've been talking about all week when
we're talking about and anything from
internet pornography to the role of
government in politics and culture you
know I waited
out a couple days ago I asked what is
the purpose of government what is the
primary purpose of government night I
listed liberty equality justice and
other and you could add other Liberty
one by a mile
it's like 61 percent to 20 percent
something like that 20 percent said
justice 60 some-odd percent said Liberty
two percent said equality good job guys
you got that one right
now I think some people said Liberty
because Liberty is such a broadly
defined word the great conservative
political philosopher Edmund Burke said
of all the political concepts Liberty
has indefinite numbers infinite numbers
of definitions when we talk about
Liberty the kind of Liberty that we like
we're talking about ordered Liberty
we're not just talking about going to
drag queens story our every night we're
talking about the kind of Liberty that
allows you to flourish and live live a
good life and order your will towards
something that's good and not toward you
know just sitting in a ditch somewhere
doing drugs and looking at internet porn
even so we should be more precise about
our language the the there this wasn't a
trick question the purpose of government
has a real answer especially in America
the father of our Constitution James
Madison answered this in Federalist 51
James Madison writing a Fed 51 wrote
justice is the end of government it is
the end of civil society it ever has
been and ever will be pursued until it
be obtained or until Liberty being lost
in the pursuit so Liberty plays a very
important role in justice you're not
going to have justice without Liberty
but merely unfettered individual Liberty
especially if it's unmoored from the
moral order is not the purpose of the
American government it's not the purpose
of any real government and the founding
fathers never thought it was and it's a
very recent idea that it was this is
this has happened over the past 40 50
years there's actually been a sort of
consensus on the right and left and the
consensus has been that the purpose of
government is Liberty even the left
believes this they're incoherent about
it but they believe it so for the left
they say we want totally expanded social
liberty sexual liberation women's
liberation abortion on demand
reproductive freedom is what they call
it right so they want social
liberté like redefining marriage
abortion all the time porn everywhere
casual sex all those sort of things
well conservatives have done is they've
taken the flip side of that coin they've
said yes the purpose of government is
just untrammeled liberty and so we want
economic liberty tax cuts deregulation
free trade that all puts the cart before
the horse because liberty is very very
important for a purpose and it's not
don't take my word for it this is not
some crazy reaction or review this is
what James Madison who is the father of
the Constitution said in the Federalist
Papers which unfortunately nobody reads
so very few people are aware of this
there is something bigger than that
which is justice there is something
bigger than that which is called it
ordered liberty social liberty the
recognition that we're not all just
atoms floating around in space that we
actually do live in society and we don't
want to be tyrannize dwee don't want to
live in some collectivist hellscape we
want our rights to be protected we want
our liberties to be protected but we
actually do have bonds to one another to
our families to our communities to our
state to our government to our people to
our civic associations we have to
recognize that because if you simply
take this hyper individualistic
atomistic idea of Liberty as the total
end of government what you're gonna end
up with is a loneliness epidemic what
you're gonna end up with is a government
that says that we have we have the right
the duty to define reality for ourselves
that's what that's what Justice Kennedy
said in Casey a Planned Parenthood to be
cacey
decades ago that we have the right to
define reality for ourselves define what
it is to be a man or a woman or that a
baby's not really a baby and that of
course is crazy libertinism is not
Liberty and you don't want to have a
lonely country one of a good country you
wanna have a free country we all love
freedom but freedom has a higher purpose
I have a piece on this at the Daily wire
if you want to if you want some more on
it which is called the porn debate isn't
really about porn but it speaks to a lot
of the social ills that we're seeing and
we've we've got to start taking a deeper
view of politics then maybe we have in
the past couple decades we have to start
taking it the deeper view that we had 50
years ago before our culture and our
politics got so hollowed out
so shallow let's get to the mailbag from
David hi hail Michal Knowles king of
trolls I was wondering if you could
explain what critical theory is it gets
mentioned very often but rarely
explained
yes critical theory is used a lot
critical theory is a highly politicized
academic approach that was developed by
Marxists of the Frankfurt School in the
1930s it has been popularly referred to
by the literary critic Harold Bloom who
recently died and was a lifelong liberal
he referred to it as the school of
resentment critical theory is where you
just deconstruct your culture where for
instance you approach literature not as
you should which is through love the
love of the poetry the love of the
images the love of human nature the love
of the story the love of academic
pursuit not through that but through
criticism resentment you read Walt
Whitman to find out how racist and
sexist and evil he was and this has been
the approach not just to literature but
to history to political science to
sociology to so many of these academic
departments critical critical theory has
taken over all of the Academy right now
and it's a very bad idea not merely
because it's so shallow and ideological
and partisan but because it actually
inverts the purpose of learning that you
know any any theory of Education or
theory of knowledge that begins with the
premise that you have to hate what
you're studying is dead wrong the only
way that you're going to learn anything
the only way that you were going to grow
in knowledge is through love actually
somebody who explains this very well is
Dante speaking of great literature
speaking of people who aren't read
anymore you know what Dante shows us is
that unity of learning of growth in
knowledge of Education and of love the
famous image that ends the poem is the
love that moves the Sun and the other
stars that there is this love that comes
with it so for especially especially
with Dante I love Dante when I read
Dante it is because I'm drawn by a love
of that and that love leads me to a
deeper understanding and leads me to
wisdom that's what should be going on in
the Academy and it's not and critical
theory plays a huge role in that from
Justin what is your favorite Christmas
movie that's a tough one
no I guess it's not jingle all the way
obviously it's the greatest one of all
what an amazing movie you get the govern
Eider you get a superhero character it's
just an amazing movie jingle all the way
next question from Abby diem as a fan of
Gavin McGinnis I've heard a lot about
the nofap and no wanks movements well I
guess I just said those things on air
the fact that he is against porn is
often trotted out as proof of his Nazi
nature why does the left love porn so
much this is unbelievable
when you go I really like Gavin you know
you get Gavin who is a comedian who's
telling people don't look at porn
because it's gonna make you into like a
weak little creepy degenerate and they
say see if you don't look at runaway
girls being abused on video all the time
you're on Nazi that's not a very
compelling argument I think it's
obviously right porn is a major social
problem regardless of what you think
about whether the government should get
involved on the local or the state at
federal level or not getting involved at
all I think we can all admit it's not
good you don't want to be a wanker you
don't want to be a guy who closes the
blinds and and looks at poor runaway
girls having strange things done to them
by strange men on high resolution video
that's not a good thing right
so Gavin comes out there and says hey
don't do that and and the left calls him
a Nazi they call a lot of they call a
lot of people Nazis they do it because
the left requires sexual Liberty nism
the left really benefits from this
libertinism
one because it compromises you so
they'll say you actually some people who
ostensibly are on the right wing even
said this in the porn debate they said
if you've ever looked at porn you can
say that we should ban porn if you've
ever looked at porn who are you to say
porn is a bad thing you're doing it
you're a hypocrite shut up so the left
wants you to do that
and the left also promotes libertinism
because the left exists to break down
the traditional order the left exists in
opposition to the tradition so anyway to
break down that tradition whether that's
marriage whether that's traditional
relationships when that's traditional
sexual desires whether that's
traditional behavior which says hey
maybe restrain your appetites and your
lusts and your you're a sexual appetite
they don't want any of those restraints
they want to break down all of their
restraints so that once the traditional
structures which they blame for all the
evils of the world
the patriarchy and the hierarchies and
the dis are key and the bad are key once
that's all breaking down then they will
just have a ton of atomized individuals
living in cultural rubble and from there
they can build their utopia from Rustom
dear Michael out of the broom closet
Knowles I'd like your thoughts on a
debate that is currently raging in my
country the Netherlands where a child
born with severe and usually terminal
birth defects can be euthanized the
government in my country is considering
easing up the laws that allow for the
murder of those children by physicians I
believe this practice is wrong but
anyone that shares my view is castigated
as an uncaring demon that wants to let
children suffer what do you think as
always love the show and a Merry
Christmas
I think woe to you that call evil good
and good evil that put darkness for
light and light for darkness that put
bitter for sweet and sweet for bitter
I'm not surprised at all that these
genuine ghouls who are advocating the
legalization of killing children are
calling you a bad guy because you want
to protect children that always happens
it's the nature of the world and
obviously that the euthanasia laws are
abhorrent they are indefensible this is
what happens when you compromise on
human dignity in your politics so it's
what happens when you when you embrace
abortion then why shouldn't you embrace
euthanasia you're saying you can kill
innocent people at one stage of life why
not in another if you've embraced
euthanasia for old people who have who
are gonna die in three days why not
embrace euthanasia for people who might
die in three months if they're suffering
why not embrace euthanasia for people
who are depressed
why not embrace euthanasia for people
who are born defective in their minds I
don't think they're defective in an
ultimate sense but they seem to they say
yeah ultimately you're a defective
you're not worth life so why not kill
them even if they're children
Netherlands has been leading the way
down that dark path
all of that is premise on the idea that
suffering is intrinsically evil and the
primary purpose if not the only purpose
of life is to feel pleasure and this is
such a perverse idea the purpose of life
is not to feel pleasure and suffering is
not in Trenton on intrinsically evil but
it can actually be helpful because it
helps us grow it deepens our experience
of life yet it prompts the moral quality
of how you respond to suffering do you
respond in a bad way or do you respond
in a good way also suffering is a fact
of life this this is what's so insidious
about this is everybody suffers a lot of
the time you don't know that from
Instagram you don't know that when you
see people and they tell you oh
everything's great I feel a lot of
people are suffering a lot of the time
that is a fact of human life and so if
you say that if someone suffers they can
end their lives if you accept that
premise then it's just a matter of time
before they come for us whether through
in the case of the Netherlands actually
holding people down and euthanizing them
meaning murdering them as has happened
or through the cultural pressure and the
cultural persuasion to off yourself if
you're not feeling happy all the time
very very bad situation a good job
standing up for life and for for it the
good from Martin last question does the
Constitution need new amendments of
separation of powers between the media
and the politicians that's a great
question I you know I have two thoughts
on this obviously it's unfortunate that
the media are such hacks for the
politicians that they so carry water for
the Democratic Party
is an unfortunate thing on the other
hand I got to hand it to reporters who
go out there and get their stories you
know in some ways you get the stories by
getting drinks with a politician
sometimes a little bit more than that
it'll at the very least - befriending a
politician getting in their good graces
I mean good dog and reporters are
actually able to kind of penetrate these
circles and and get good scoops I think
that's a wonderful thing we don't need
to change the constitution the media are
not addressed in the Constitution but we
we should have a code of ethics for
journalists that would be a nice thing
and for the journalistic outlets that do
have codes of ethics New York Times
Washington Post it would be nice if they
actually abided by them and if they
don't we'll just have to tune the map I
guess we're already doing that today
you'll have to tune me out right now but
be sure to come back on Monday I have a
good weekend in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you next week
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]